(Oh hi any closer?)
Hello minna-san, konnichiwa (hello everyone, good afternoon), it's me. Yes, another day in Japan.
So what do I do when I spend my time here? Looking at reddit, baby.
That's what we're doing here today because no one's ever done that. Pushing the boundaries on what is content here on YouTube!
I did find it really interesting
Well, actually I didn't find it, Dave from Boyinaband sent it to me. Arigato gozaimasu, Dave. (Thank you very much Dave)
He sent me this really funny reddit. It's called "Awful taste but great execution."
For everything that displays quality craftsmanship in the least elegant way possible
It's basically as if you were extremely talented at something that no one cares about.
That's essentially this reddit.
A  woman crocheted. Is that how you say that?
herself and her dog
See I saw the dog first and then I look up and I'm like oh god
Why would you do that?
Why for the love of God would you do that? That takes a long-ass time to do that as well?
You don't just wake up one morning and go I'm gonna crochet not just myself but my dog and it's gonna be epic
You know, if she did it for the meme I can understand but you know
She didn't do it for the meme so there will be no respect from me
Okay a long time lurker
Then I saw this and just had to share what in the god's name of Earth am I looking at okay
Those are the eyes
Why would you make this you know
My car is really nice and all but I would really prefer it for it to be a hippo
Who says that?
I just really love hippos. They're so great. But really I want to drive a hippo don't you understand?
You don't understand. I love hippos! Found on Craigslist. I have no words. I mean Mater is a great character
At least I understand this, cuz it makes sense to be a fan of that wonderful film known as Cars 2
Yeah, I would say this is actually awesome taste and great execution. Good job!
This one wins. Congratulations!
German police stops car with what turns out to be a blood sticker
No charges because awful taste is not a crime
Jesus Christ I like (awful taste)
Can you imagine the police reaction be like we should probably stop that car
Jesus Christ
You forget really how bad taste people have, not like me impeccable taste. I mean
Couldn't be better than this. Heard you guys might
Appreciate this velvet in Mercedes. I saw
Jesus Christ, I've actually seen these I saw this in Beverly Hills I saw a velvet
Was it a Mustang? I don't know, it actually looked good. This looks terrible. I I don't know what difference in me
Kind of want to pee on that. I don't know what
Don't judge me okay, I like peeing on things that are ugly. I'm just beginning to see a theme here with the car changes
Now why would you do that?
Why would you do that? Can I get my brand-new van to look twenty years old?
Thanks
Well, at least now you don't have to worry about it aging actually makes perfect sense
It's a distracting that I have my hand up here because it's quite comfortable. This is an abomination! :O
Why would you do that? I don't understand. I just I just don't understand. I need to know the context
So the ear goes around the neck, I mean that's clever
Does it look good? Absolutely not. Is it clever and funny? Yes. Oh my god. Yes!
Preach it guys. This is what I'm talking talking about. It's not just this you see a lot of guys get their beard, like
Perfect line and
Perfect. The way the way they go to like a barber and they're like, yeah, I'm gonna hook you up
We're gonna get you the best goddamn beard cut ever and then it just looks like, it looks disgusting
It makes me sick. Are you tell me this' supposed to look good? That looks f****** terrible. Look at this, dude
Look at him! *laughs*
This is what I see this is oh god, no, please
Awful taste great execution my god. Is that Jesus Christ Jesus of Natherens as a balloon crucifixion
I don't know about you guys
But I kind of like it and I at least appreciate the artistry that went behind this
I feel like..  don't you know someone like this? Someone's Cousin, someones uncle, they're like
Yeah, I had this passion project that I've been working on for like 30 years and you can tell they're talented
But then you look at it and you're like: That's just f***ing awful! Saw this on Facebook!
I don't know. This is kinda' cool.
I don't know what to tell you. Did you guys know that the "skiftnyckeln" is a Swedish invention. You're welcome the world. It's also showing your pEepEe size.
HAHAHAHAHAHAHA *ironic*
This Reddit makes me uncomfortable. I don't know about you guys. I feel sick. This dentist ?room waiting?
The thing is like also all the money that went into this not just the time
This is like the investments people make to create these abominations.
OH
MY
F***ing
God
What is that?
Stop crocheting
People okay, that should be banned I would rather they ban this than any other bad things murder, theft, fine
Ban this! Please ban crocheting people. Has anyone ever went: "Hey, I would like a crocheted baby, please."
I just don't understand. I have so many questions. Oh my god. What is this a teeth? Oh God!
F**k
Stop
Just stop. This is why people's need to stop being creative. This is why those "hug don't hug me I'm scared videos" exist.
Stop being creative. It's not for you, man
Wallet chain ankle "crocs"
In case someone steals your crocs
It would be like "hahaha gotcha bet you didn't think I wore"
It's a stylistic choice (swedish accent)
Now, why would you want that on your chest? Oh my god.
What am I looking at?
This whole thing just makes me uncomfortable. I feel sick!
Smash like if you're feeling sick right now just so I can know how many people fe- there they are!! There they are!! I've covered about these
They are like four thousand. Yeah, I I remember asking in the video who on God's earth with their right mind would get one of these
and then literally the day after
Filthy Frank's cousin.
I don't know if he actually is his cousin. There's a tweet saying oh, yeah, Ezra is my cousin, that's a pretty known fact
Why would you do that?
The balls the balls to pull up on one of these
That's some huge balls, okay
I can appreciate that. I can only appreciate them for the meme but I can't tell if he's meming alt-reality filthy Frank
I don't know what to tell you man.
A duct tape car
Jesus Christ, I mean it looks smooth.
I Don't want to tell you man, awful taste grace great execution. You did a good job. You taped your car.
Oh god this makes me sick. I feel so weird.
What is that? Oh
And I agree, I hate it. I hate it!
It's so impressive, but I hate it!
What in the god's name is that she has to drawer on her shoe
She has chocolate in it, what does she have
She has 20 chocolates
In her shoe Oh God, I mean why not? I mean why not at this point?
Why the Frick not
This is upside down truck
Stop! Stop it!
Stop it! I mean that looks dope. No? Does that not look dope?
I think that looks dope. Does that mean I have awful taste?
F**k. What is this doggy Doo-doo firework? Oh god. I really want to see this
Okay, does s**t come out? It does of course
That's awesome.
Oh My god
This is me when I have Mexican (Swedish accent. Ew Felix that's nasty)
Jesus Christ
This is every s**t that Edgar has.
Custom dog slippers made to look like your dog
I think that dog's face summarizes my reaction pretty well.
I kind of like this. I think sometimes I do have awful taste
Can I have one of those haircuts, please
Finish the artwork, please
It looks good, it looks really good.
I'm certainly think we need to ban crocheting just say in General.
Just ban it I'm sorry. If you're a fellow crochetster not a fellow crochetster a nine-year-old crochester. Is that what it's called?
Crochester? I'm gonna call it that
You're gonna have to stop we're putting you to prison. There should be some sort of creative law. Someone makes an abomination
They just get thrown to jail be like sorry. This crochet was just so bad. You're going to prison now
You contribute nothing. Therefore you will go to jail and think about what you've done
Lightning McQueen
Tron Ferrari that
F**k it's kind of cool. Goddammit
It's like one of those things where it might have a personal attachment for you and everyone... I get it now
I think I got it. Yeah, that's what it is
It's like one of those things that you have a personal attachment to
And then maybe the people around you know, that that's the thing that you really like
So when they get it, they're so proud of it. So everyone else around and go like wow
That's so great. We're so proud of you meanwhile on the internet:
Pfff (*loser*)
Like this guy he probably likes teeth, you know, and he's like I have this Mustang and..
I really want teeth on it. I don't know. I'm trying to make sense of f***ing insane people here. Okay god damn it
Why would you do that?
Now? Why would you do that?
And why would you give your haircut a haircut?
Don't give your haircut a f***ing haircut
Goddamnit. Stop.
Stop being creative
aaaah God (And this is where he loses his mind)
I can't take it anymore frosted tips Oh God. Why does a it's 2019 stop getting frosted tips! For the love of God staaaaahphaha
I can't take it anymore! Lady wanted her husband's bite mark...is it what the faack what the (*inhales saliva*)
(*heavy breathing*)
(*still slurping saliva XD*)
ahh
I'm losing it. I can't do this (told you)
Jeans..
Manicure... For f**k sake
It's disgusting what is that? What am I looking at?
I see you guys tomorrow
Oh! Before you leave got one important announcement 90 million Club merch. Have you gotten in yet?
It's time to do your part. Thank you represent.com/pewdiepie See you guys tomorrow
Bye!
Manicure... For f**k sake
It's disgusting. What is that? What am I looking at?
Tuber simulator
It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new minigame:
"Craniac" :D
drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of course there is
New knowledge perks, new quests, and new pixelings and legs, guys:
LEGS!
düdüdüdüdüdü THIS GAME IS STILL RELEVANT!